[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de la grande interview on reçoit
aujourd'hui frédéric ploquin grand
reporter journaliste d'investigation
spécialisé dans les affaires criminelles
frédéric ploquin bonjour merci d'être
avec nous je disais vous êtes donc
l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages
documentaires article sur des
thématiques telles que le grand
banditisme la police vous suivez toute
cette affaire depuis plus de 30 ans
maintenant et vous signez se livrent les
narcos français brise l'omerta aux
éditions albin michel le fruit d'un long
travail qui vous a permis d'obtenir des
témoignages rares on va en parler si
bien qu'on à la fois une vision globale
et très détaillée de ce phénomène
et quand on lit votre livre une des
questions qu'on se pose tout de suite
c'est comment vous avez réussi à créer
ce lien de confiance entre vos
interlocuteurs et vous notamment avec
les plus jeunes dont on n'imagine pas
forcément qu'ils ont envie de se livrer
facilement la drogue c'est un sujet dont
on entend parler comme ça régulièrement
ça fait une brève ici une brève là dans
la presse on voit ici 200 kilos saisis
100 kg saisi 300 kilos 600 kg et
finalement je j'ai considéré qu on
s'était habitué à cette espèce de
refrains de ritournelles comme ça de ces
irrégulière et que on oublier quelque
part on avait oublié que la drogue était
un sujet qui nous concerne est tous
simplement parce que c'était un petit
peu rentrées de rentrer dans le paysage
donc je me suis dit il faut aller voir
de l'autre côté du décor et c'est vrai
que la chance que j'ai c'est que ça fait
plus de trente ans maintenant que je
travaille que je laboure entre
guillemets ce terrain et j'ai toujours
veillé dans mon travail de journaliste
ce qui est à mon avis la plus grande
difficulté mais à rester en mesure
d'interroger les deux camps si je puis
dire c'est à dire le camp des biens et
le candidat et donc j'ai toujours
cultivé depuis plus de 30 ans des
relations avec des policiers des
magistrats mais beaucoup de policiers
qui notamment en l'occurrence ont
travaillé contre le trafic de
stupéfiants ce qui me permet d'avoir
tout lé à la profondeur de champ et de
raconter comment la lutte contre les
stupéfiants lui est en gros depuis la
french connection la découverte de
l'héroïne à l'époque jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'un côté et puis de l'autre côté c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué mais
je fréquente le milieu du grand
banditisme à titre journalistique c'est
pas c'est pas voilà je ne fais pas des
voyous forcément nécessairement des amis
mais des contacts j'ai installé une
relation de confiance avec eux qui fait
que je vais les voir en prison
je vais les voir quelquefois quand ils
sont dans la nature mais c'était un peu
plus compliqué parfois et jeu et j'ai
installé en fait une certaine confiance
c'est à dire qu il ne me viendrait
jamais à l'idée en tant que journaliste
d'informer un policier sur ce que fait
un bandit ou d'informer un bandit sur ce
que fait un policier la police et je
pense que c'est ça la ligne un peu de
crête sur laquelle il faut naviguer pour
rester en gros en vie et pas avoir
d'ennuis avec avec celui de la donc
ensuite l'autre chose qu'il faut que
j'ajoute si vous voulez c'est que dans
le banditisme notamment en matière de
trafic de stupéfiants une génération
forme l'autre et moi je me suis appuyé
sur les anciens effectivement pour
approcher des plus jeunes qui sont un
petit peu plus compliqué effectivement à
aborder que les anciens officiellement
rangé des voitures ou pas c'est
peut-être un petit peu plus facile de
voilà d'aller leur faire raconter leurs
souvenirs de la découverte de la cocaïne
comme on y vendait dans les années 80 la
cocaïne à jet set parisienne ça s'est
relativement plus simple que d'aller
effectivement aujourd'hui au pied de la
tour dans tel quartier interrogés parce
que je ne voulais pas que m'intéresser
aux patrons mais également aux petites
mains de la drogue pour les écouter pour
les comprendre pour pour comprendre ce
qu'ils avaient dans la tête pour
comprendre quelles étaient leurs modèles
pour les entendre et donc les certaine
manière j'ai procédé comme ça c'est à
dire que les anciens
ont recommandé auprès des plus jeunes
après la confiance s'est installée et
après j'ai envie de vous dire et ça
c'est à mon avis c'est une information
importante à noter si vous voulez ils se
sentent aujourd'hui tellement sûrs d'eux
les trafiquants de stupéfiants
un peu comme s'il avait comme s'ils
estimaient qu'ils avaient gagné la
bataille ils se sentent tellement sûrs
d'eux qu'en réalité le premier contact
est toujours un peu compliqué puis le
deuxième un petit peu moins et puis
après après je les revoyais deux fois
trois fois quatre fois cinq fois et
après je me rendais compte que ça ne le
dérangeait pas d'exposer leur vie leur
façon de faire leurs voix leurs procédés
leur l'heureuse maman est justement de
tout ce que vous décrivez dans votre
livre de façon très détaillée vous
d'abord vous poser une question dont
beaucoup ces derniers temps dans
l'actualité des phénomènes de deux rixes
entre bandes rivales notamment en région
parisienne quel regard vous portez vous
sur ces événements écoutez moi je les
observe avec attention ces rixes et pour
moi d'une certaine manière c'est un
petit peu ces rixes sont un petit peu
lent l'antichambre des gangs de demain
c'est à dire qu'en gros vous avez des
des individus extrêmement jeune 12 13 14
15 ans et ce qu'on voit dans les rixes
récemment en france d'ailleurs
c'est le profil de l'âge des victimes 15
ans et donc en réalité c'est un espèce
de passage obligé vers l'âge adulte où
vous vous avez 14 15 ans vous commencez
à défendre le quartier dans lequel la
auquel vous appartenez dans lequel vous
avez grandi
vous défendez le quartier vous défendez
l'image du quartier vous défendez la
réputation du quartier vous fait corps
comme ça en grandissant avec le quartier
et d'une certaine façon vous devenez un
homme c'est cruel de dire ce que je vais
dire mais c'est la vérité vous devenez
un homme en vous affrontant physiquement
avec les plus avec les autres avec les
rivaux avec les concurrents au départ
dans un contexte qui n'est pas forcément
lié à l'économie souterraine où
l'économie parallèle mais dans un second
temps vous allez être d'une certaine
façon sélectionnés par les plus âgés qui
vont vous choisir qui vont dire vers lui
lui s'est bien comportée là il ad
excusez moi l'expression il a des
couilles parce que c'est un mot qui
revient extrêmement régulièrement quand
je les écoute c'est le mot cool c'est
vraiment voilà en fait pour devenir un
homme
il faut il faut savoir se battre pour
avoir envie de se battre faut pas avoir
peur des adversaires des autres et pas
avoir peur évidemment de la police parce
que c'est aussi ça c'est aussi une
espèce d'accoutumance régulière au fait
que la police est un empêcheur de
tourner en rond la police
ensuite devient un ennemi la police
devient ensuite au bout du compte celui
qui veut vous empêcher de deal est
tranquillement vous parler de comment on
accède à ce business parfois de façon
parfois quand on est très jeune il ya
deux témoignages notamment dans votre
livre alors je précise évidemment que
les noms ont été changés dans votre
livre il ya donc crise et sadio crise
qui présente son activité en vantant
l'argent facile il explique qu'il a
démarré très tôt aux alentours de 10 11
ans alors qu'elle inverse ça de lui à
commencer bien plus tard ils n'étaient
pas forcément prédestiné à entrer dans
ce milieu comment on accède aujourd'hui
à cette économie parallèle
on y accède précisément parce qu'on est
sélectionné par les plus anciens parce
que en fait les les points de deal il ya
deux façons de fait les points de deal
d'une certaine manière se transmettent
c'est à dire que celui qui le
et à 20 ans un moment donné il va
peut-être se passer à autre chose parce
que on n'est pas forcément dealer toute
sa vie il faut pas le voir comme ça et
soi soit on le remonte un petit peu en
grade
on accède un peu à aso au monde de ce
qui importe en plus grosse quantité
le produit et on laisse le terrain dont
il ya une espèce de système de jeu
dirais presque de location bail quoi
comme ça des espèces dont cède son pas
de porte à des plus jeunes qui eux vont
s'exposer vont être en première ligne
vis-à-vis de la police nous parlait même
de pme c'est quasiment dpm est
aujourd'hui alors effectivement sur le
terrain en france comme ça on a des
centaines
des centaines de petites pme mais au
final tellement d'argent qui est drainée
par ce trafic que moi je parle vraiment
carrément de multinationales je sais
c'est une multinationale à l'échelle de
la planète les stupéfiants avec des
ramifications dans le monde entier et je
dirais même ce sont ceux sont les
trafiquants de drogue d'une certaine
façon qui sont peut-être les meilleurs
adeptes de la de la mondialisation c'est
à dire que ils ont inventé les routes de
la drogue bien avant que les entreprises
ne découvrent les bienfaits de la
mondialisation
ils ont cassé les frontières ils ont
cassé les balais barrière c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu aller voir les anciens
aussi les anciens qui à l'époque de la
colonisation de la colonisation sont
implantés dans des territoires lointains
ont commencé à récupérer le produit et
c'est donc ces jeunes qu'on voit
aujourd'hui sur le terrain sont les
héritiers de ces pionniers je dirais en
matière de trafic de drogue on peut
considérer que les boyaux français ont
été d'un certaine façon des pionniers
des inventeurs on va dire bien avant que
la mafia calabraise mexicaine
colombienne ne s'installe les français
étaient déjà sur le produit de l'héroïne
au point d'ailleurs à l'époque de faire
de faire un clash au niveau
international puisqu'il a fallu que le
président des états unis se déplace pour
aller voir le président français à
l'époque c'était
georges pompidou pour lui dire écoute ça
suffit on en a marre d'être envahi par
le produit par la blanche ce qu'on
appelait la banque
la blanche par l'héroïne française il
faut faire quelque chose donc ces jeunes
qui sont là sur le terrain ils sont les
héritiers de cela ils sont les héritiers
d'une culture et moi ce qui me frappe
c'est voler c'est que très vite très
jeune il intègre les codes de la mafia
je crois qu'ils regardent aussi beaucoup
de séries télévisées je crois que ils
sont ils sont à fond sur les séries
mexicaines sur chapeau sur tout ça est
sûre et sur cette violence qui s'est
banalisée par l'intermédiaire des séries
télévisées notamment
ils sont à fond là dedans et il adopte
de manière extrêmement fidèle les codes
très jeune il adopte sa les codes en
gros du système mafieux à dire l'omerta
la parole donnée
la loi du plus fort
plus en plus dormir il comparé aux plus
anciens c'est à dire que moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que la violence des anciens
elle se se produisait on va dire
essentiellement dans le cadre de
règlements de comptes où il fallait
éliminer quelqu'un qui était soupçonné
d'être de travailler pour la police
d'être une balance entre guillemets ou
bien un concurrent ou bien voilà c'était
que ça maintenant aujourd'hui les motifs
de l'exercice de la violence beaucoup
plus utile c'est ça qui est frappant
dire qu'on a la même la même violence
celle des des grands bandits on va dire
mais exercer pour des motifs qui
paraissent totalement parfois totalement
dérisoire c'est un peu surprenant
surprenant mais je dire autrefois quand
quand les grands voyous français
descendent et leurs collègues à la cave
comme ils disaient ils descendent à la
cas pour le torturer pour lui pour lui
pour obtenir de l'argent pour le faire
parler pour en général pour lui faire
cracher du pognon il y avait des grosses
sommes en jeu et puis on était au sommet
de la voyoucratie française et
aujourd'hui on voit ce type de
comportement partout s'être répondu
c'est ça qui est quand même la grande
voile à la grande surprise du moment
c'est l'extension sur tout le territoire
à la fois dû à la fois du produit
stupéfiant de produits stupéfiants n'est
plus comme autrefois consommer
uniquement ou vendu dans une quarantaine
de quartiers sensibles bien identifiés
maintenant c'est un phénomène national
et on le voit y compris dans des zones
rurales
se répandre avec ce modèle comme ça qui
est copiée à l'infini par mimétisme par
les jeunes ça a changé du coup le profil
des dealers on imagine que le fait que
le produit comme vous le dites et
répandu maintenant sur tout le
territoire est ce qu'on a des profils de
dealers différent puisqu'on sait aussi
que la drogue investi toutes les couches
sociales
aujourd'hui dans le pays effectivement
il peut y avoir des surprises bon
globalement quand même le deal de rue
est tenu par des jeunes issus des
quartiers qui ont grandi dans les
quartiers souvent ils sont issus de
familles qui sont les derniers à arriver
sur le plan de l'immigration ils sont
pas intégrés ils ont des parents qui
comprennent pas vraiment ce que font les
gamins dans la rue moi j'ai rencontré
concrètement des mamans qui ignorait
totalement que l'or blanc leur petit
dernier faisait le le chouf au pied de
la tour en bas tous les jours je veux
dire des moments qu'ils ne savaient pas
donc là on a là je parle vraiment de du
deal de rue de ce qui se passe dans la
rue a ensuite un peu au dessus
effectivement et notamment en période de
crise économique sociale dans leur
l'occurrence la crise sanitaire qui nous
frappe aujourd'hui on peut avoir et j'ai
vu un certain nombre de personnes tout à
fait a priori comme ça
honorable sur tous les plans des
commerçants en difficulté des gens
basculer de l'autre côté ça ça existe
aussi c'est à dire qu'on a des gens qui
à un moment donné vont basculer parce
que parce que il croit que la drogue
c'est un argent relativement facile à
obtenir mais en fait
en fait c'est pas si facile que ça ait
en fait il faut quand même avoir les
codes pour comprendre et on risque sa
peau à tout moment et il ya un certain
nombre de règles que tout le monde ne
connaît pas et donc moi j'ai des dealers
là dans des gros trafiquants dans le
bouquin qui disent mais les filles qui
témoigne de l'église ne m'attendais moi
j'ai rencontré des dégâts là qu'est ce
qu'ils font là dedans ça va mal se finir
pour eux effectivement tout le monde ne
peut pas se lancer
heureusement d'ailleurs dans le trafic
de stupéfiants mais la tentation existe
dans la mesure où l'échelle d'une petite
ville j'ai pas de province lambda on
peut se dire maintien lors effectivement
et dans un premier temps c'est vrai ça
rapporte
ça rapporte quand vous pensez qu'un kilo
de cocaïne
au pays parce que pour cette enquête je
suis allé jusque en colombie rencontré
des français qui la bat exporte la
cocaïne vers la france la balle touche
le kilo de cocaïne à 1200 euros
il arrive en france ce même kilo de
cocaïne
il se revend environ à 30 mille euros il
se coupe une fois ou deux fois donc on
arrive déjà encore 1 x 2 une fois qu'on
a mis des produits chimiques pour
augmenter le poids et au final si vous
aussi vous imaginez vous multipliez cela
par le nombre de grammes vendus dans la
rue c'est vrai que c'est une fête la
drogue c'est une pompe à fric comme il y
en a aucune autre avec peloton va
marquer une pause on revient dans
quelques instants pour continuer de
parler avec vous de ce livre les narcos
français brise l'omerta
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
frédéric ploquin journaliste
d'investigation hauteur de les narcos
français brise l'omerta on a parlé un
petit peu de l'étendue du problème sur
le territoire vous parlez également
beaucoup du blanchiment d'argent avec
notamment le témoignage d'un certain
jean marie qui semble montrer que c'est
finalement assez simple aujourd'hui de
blanchir l'argent sale issu du trafic de
drogue c'est vrai qu'on se pose toujours
la question de savoir
comment les trafiquants achemine
jusqu'au consommateur des kilos et des
kilos de produits mais on se pose
beaucoup moins souvent la question de
savoir comment des kilos de biais de
banques retournent chez le fournisseur
et c'est ça que j'ai voulu creuser comme
voilà j'ai voulu en savoir un peu plus
sur sur sur ce phénomène parce
qu'effectivement si on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son gant garou
dans son garage des billets de banque
nota n'y de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose donc il
ya là plusieurs sortes de blanchiment
effectivement il ya le blanchiment si
j'ose dire bas de gamme en bas de
l'échelle où on va blanchir un peu à
proximité les blanchiments de proximité
on pourra dire dans le quartier où on va
acheter racheter pourquoi pas la
boulangerie le petit face ou de le kebab
ouvrir un petit salon massage
ça c'est vraiment le blanchiment en bas
ensuite au niveau un tout petit peu
supérieur il ya un certain nombre de
trafiquants de stupéfiants qui ont la
chance d'avoir des attaches dans des
pays lointains
je pense notamment ça peut être
l'afrique noire ça peut être le maghreb
etc
donc ça c'est le deuxième niveau de
blanchiment vous avez une partie de
l'argent qu'ils retournent dans ces pays
qui est investi localement j'ai
rencontré un un petit jeune comme ça
c'est totalement improbable qui
travaillent dans une petite qui
travaillent qui dealent qui vont kiffer
voilà qui est dealer dans une petite
cité en france et qui à acheter
je vous le donne en mille une crêperie
non dans une capitale afrique et
africaine donc pourquoi pas je dirais
tout est possible à ce niveau là sachant
que les banques notamment les banques
un certain nombre de banques étrangères
on va dire pas forcément les banques
les principales banques françaises qui
sont ultra surveillé mais à côté de ça
vous avez tout un réseau de banques qui
sont beaucoup plus ouverte au cash
il faut le dire il faut le dire je veux
dire en période de crise les banques
même les plus connus à l'époque de la
crise de 2008 vous dit même que les
banques qui ont été beaucoup moins
regardante sur la provenance de cet
argent qui arrivaient pour renflouer les
caisses
absolument ce que raconte la notamment
jean-marie lassausse ce trafic en
français c'est que lui il a absolument
aucun problème à partir du moment où
l'argent est rentré dans la caisse à
aller dans une petite succursale même
d'une banque française pourquoi pas dans
l'est dans les antilles dans les
caraïbes où il ya plein de petits îlots
où il ya quasiment plus établissements
bancaires que que deux bateaux de pêche
il faut dire la vérité donc à partir de
là il ya une vraie perméabilité et en
2008 ça a été même dit aux nations unies
on a constaté que que plusieurs dizaines
de milliards on va dire issus d'argent
sale donc issus du trafic de stupéfiants
notamment mecs du mexique qui comme la
la grande plateforme de la drogue dans
le monde aujourd'hui ont été absorbés
par un certain nombre de banques aux
états unis qui d'ailleurs ont été
poursuivis en justice et ont plaidé
coupable et ont payé des amendes en
conséquence mais sans plus de dégâts que
ça donc effectivement il ya une vraie
perméabilité je veux dire l'argent sale
l'argent sale
devient devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
depuis lé pays on va en citer
quelques-uns mais si on sait on pense
par exemple à dubai aujourd'hui dubai
aujourd'hui et les dorado des
trafiquants français ils sont tous
installés là-bas ils ont tous acheté un
appartement deux appartements et puis il
ya des choses plus surprenante je veux
dire vous avez aussi des pays asiatiques
je pense notamment à hong kong ou à la
chine où là il suffit que vous déclariez
c'est du déclaratif qu'en gros l'argent
que vous amenez vient de la fraude
fiscale pour qu'on fasse un petit
sourire entendu
ok très bien monsieur n'y a pas de
problème et vous vous mettez ça sur un
compte et après écoute et l'argent
l'argent devient rentre vite dans un
circuit et se mêle au reste des flux
financiers et cette série m'échappe
complètement aux autorités françaises à
ce moment-là dire qu'on ne peut plus
rien faire une fois que l'argent la
série en territoire on peut plus rien
faire
bah disons que c'est très difficile déjà
de saisir des biens qui sont à
l'étranger c'est extrêmement difficile
la justice française elle bute sur
partout sur des sur des des autorités
locales qui ne répondent pas quasiment
jamais aux demandes qui sont faites donc
à partir du moment où vous avez mis une
société écran puis une deuxième puis un
troisième
en fait c'est extrêmement difficile à
tracer c'est un peu c'est un peu comme
une goutte d'huile dans dans l'océan si
vous voulez à partir du moment où elle
se dilue pas écouté allez allez aller la
rechercher ça devient extrêmement
compliqué et en plus on peut pas dire
que ces dernières années on peut pas
dire non plus que c'est la lutte contre
le large en salle a été une priorité des
autorités
c'est à dire la police française à un
certain nombre de chats à fouetter si
j'ose dire beaucoup de travail et
jusqu'à récemment la lutte contre
l'argent sale était pas vraiment
considéré comme comme une priorité
nationale il ya tellement de choses qui
absorbe au quotidien la police qu'elle
n'a pas forcément les moyens
de faire le boulot dans ce domaine alors
vous expliquez que pendant longtemps le
fait de taper les trafiquants au
portefeuille n'était pas vraiment une
priorité pour la police qui avait même
des bisbilles internes entre les
différents services que ce soit les
stups ou la brigade financière ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça a un peu évolué ou
parler notamment de saisies de biens
immobiliers qui commence à être plus
fréquemment dû écouter effectivement ça
fait ça fait dix ans qu'on en parle et
au bout de dix ans a commencé un petit
peu à se mettre en place mais
fondamentalement dans la police
française il y avait une culture qui
faisait que celui qui s'occupait des
bandits s'occuper des bandits celui qui
s'occupait des trafiquants s'occuper des
trafiquants ils ont mis des années à
comprendre que ça pouvait être les mêmes
et celui qui s'occupait des flux
d'argent sale n'avait pas de contact
avec celui qui s'occupait des
trafiquants donc là aujourd'hui on a
quand même une génération de policiers
qui ont compris qu'ils arrivent aux
manettes un petit peu qu'ils ont compris
qu'on pouvait plus on pouvait plus
dissocier tout ça que c'était on pouvait
plus fonctionner comme ils disent en
tuyaux d'orgue avec des gens vous voyez
bien ce que c'est des tuyaux d'orgue sa
montre comme ça qu'il n'y a pas deux il
ya pas de passerelle entre les deux ils
ont compris que ça ne pouvait plus
fonctionner comme ça mais après il ya
d'autres difficultés c'est vrai que
quand vous lutter contre l'argent sale
tôt ou tard vous pouvez aussi tombé sur
l'argent de la fraude fiscale pourquoi
pas les financements politiques c'est ce
qui est arrivé à une époque parce qu'en
fait les tuyaux sont les mêmes
fondamentalement je mets qu'on revienne
déranger qu'on revienne en france avec
un ancien commissaire à la retraite qui
vous parle de la seine saint denis comme
d'un arc au département s'agit de serge
castello donc le 93 est un arc au
département il évoque un peu le lien
entre la politique et le trafic de
stupéfiants je cite un extrait leur
puissance financière est telle qu'ils
peuvent s'infiltrer dans les lieux de
pouvoir et peser sur le plan politique
au moins localement ce n'est pas la cosa
nostra avec sa coupole mais une
juxtaposition d'entreprises
individuelles
est-ce que ce lien entre la politique
locale au moins et les trafiquants est
vraiment si étendue que sa fille voulait
ça a commencé comment ça a commencé par
ses longues années où les pouvoirs
municipaux locaux sur ces territoires là
notamment dans le 93 ont préféré en gros
retenue à la main policière pour pour
faire simple au nom d'une espèce de paix
sociale
qu'on achetait et donc on a laissé
s'installer une espèce de loi d'ordre
parallèles on va dire dans ces quartiers
qui est maintenant tellement bien
installé qu'il est extrêmement difficile
à éradiquer on va dire parce que parce
que ça fait des générations que ça dure
donc on a eu sa et à un moment donné
effectivement on n'est pas en france la
france n'est pas le brésil le mexique on
n'a pas non plus la mafia italienne
on n'en est pas là mais ça se passe
autrement et effectivement il ya de
corruption malgré remets absolument il
ya un an il ya effectivement sur le
terrain une espèce de perméabilité qui
fait que à un moment donné qui et quel
est l'objectif d'un élu local il est
d'être élu et puis si possible d'être
réélu à un moment donné le problème
c'est que ces quartiers dans lesquels
dans lesquelles s'est installée on va
dire cette économie souterraine
ces quartiers sont aussi des réservoirs
électoraux et donc on a vu un certain
nombre de cas où
où en gros on a on a vu des équipes
municipales n'a pas hésité à s'appuyer
sur les petits caïds locaux pour essayer
de déplacer les gens vers les bureaux de
vote
et évidemment je ne sais pas un service
rendu à sens unique c'est un service
pour un service c'est toujours comme ça
avec avec le banditisme s'est jamais je
te rends service gratuitement donc on a
vu un certain nombre de d'élus se
griller les ailes
je pense notamment à marseille mais en
région parisienne et pour arriver à ce
que ce commissaire de police là
messieurs castello qui est quand même
été vains patron de la scène delà de la
sécurité publique en seine-saint-denis
pour que lui qui est quand même un homme
de l'art un professionnel utilise ce mot
de narco département c'est qu'il sait
qu'il a si j'ose dire des billets les
éléments pour le pour le dire parce
qu'on dit pas ça en l'air et
effectivement on a un département où il
ya tous les signes en fait d'aider
phénomène mafieux la mafia c'est quoi
ces camps c'est quand justement le
pouvoir économique le pouvoir politique
et le pouvoir criminel s'entendent
s'accordent sur des objectifs communs à
un moment donné est effectivement là on
a un certain nombre de points comme ça
de de partage d'intérêt commun qui font
que on peut s'appuyer quand on est élu
sur des caïds locaux parce qu'ils vont
en gros en gros ils ont un avantage
comme les voyous c'est qu'ils tiennent
un petit peu les quartiers c'est à dire
qu'en gros on peut avoir
on peut avoir un calme au moins un
parent une espèce de voile pays peuvent
même on peut même avoir des caïds
installé dans le trafic de stupéfiants
qui d'une certaine manière empêche les
vols empêche les vols à l'arraché
empêche une contiennent une certaine
forme de criminalité parce que cette
criminalité visible des rangs les
dérange dans la mesure où elle va va
faire venir la police
donc voilà on a des intérêts partagés
qui fait qu' on arrive en france
aujourd'hui à pouvoir parler de narco
département notamment à propos de la
cette année vous avez également
recueilli le témoignage de policier qui
sont encore en exercice notamment ça ne
sent ni d'ailleurs on sent qu'ils sont
partagés entre une forme de
d'abattement ils sentent qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément les moyens de pouvoir les
armes égales contre les trafiquants et
puis il ya cette phrase d'emmanuel
macron qui date de 2018 ce qui est clair
c'est qu'on a perdu la bataille du
trafic dans de nombreuses cités comment
ils réagissent les policiers quand ils y
voient les pouvoirs publics comme ça à
abandonner mais on n'y est pas loin
concernant la police il ya plusieurs cas
vous avez une toute petite mine une
toute petite minorité de policiers qui
peuvent abandonner la partie
voire même basculer de l'autre côté et
ça jeanjean j'en ai je raconte un
certain nombre de cas dans le livre
effectivement de policiers qui à un
moment donné se sont dit bon bah on est
on est abandonné par le les pouvoirs
politiques qu'on nous laisse tout seul
en première ligne dans des quartiers les
plus pourris on ne nous aide pas la
justice nous soutient pas et c'est donc
pourquoi pas aller piquer dans la poche
des dealers en gros un buzz
encore une fois faut que je le rappelle
ça concerne une infime minorité de
fonctionnaires mais il y en a qui
bascule après à côté de ça vous avez 20
éventuellement quelques-uns aussi qu'ils
vont dire bon allez c'est sert plus à
rien de se battre
j'en fais trop 60 heures par jour je
rentre à la maison je vois pas ma femme
je vois pas mes enfants album etc
je vais lever le pied ça ça peut
concerner aussi une partie des
fonctionnaires mais la plupart de ceux
que j'ai rencontrés sont quand même des
gens qui sont des vrais bons soldats
c'est à dire qu'en gros qui se battent
qui continuent à se battre qu'ils
croient qu'ils ont la foi dans leur
métier et ça s'est il faut le dire aussi
qu'ils ont la foi et qui tous les matins
se lèvent en disant bon allez je vais
aller courir après machin même si j'ai
déjà arrêté trois fois je vais leur est
arrêté même si la 14 15 ans et que la
justice leur là je vais retourner à lui
mettre la main dessus
j'aimerais bien lui coller une baffe
mais je peux pas parce qu'aujourd'hui on
peut plus coller une baffe aux voyous
mais je vais quand même faire mon boulot
donc quand même l'écrasante majorité des
policiers ça on peut les en remercie en
tant que citoyens vont tous les matins
au boulot avec cette espèce de fois
comme ça chevillé au corps et je sais je
défie je défie beaucoup de gens de de le
faire avec autant d'énergie parce que je
vous assure c'est pas forcément simple 2
de se dire lui c'est la dixième fois que
je le chope il a pas encore réussi à se
débarrasser du produit je vais pas avoir
de preuves puis c'est trop compliqué et
puis la procédure la procédure est trop
complexe et joue contre moi je défie
beaucoup de gens de faire ça avec autant
d'énergie
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
mondialisation puis on le voit dans
votre livre vous parlez de ses
frontières plutôt perméable quel impact
a eu la crise sanitaire la crise du coc
vide sur le trafic international
notamment le trafic international se se
dissimule derrière les flux de transit
de marchandises dès lors que les
marchandises continuer à circuler ce qui
est quand même relativement le cas
aujourd'hui
le produit peut se dissimuler
alors ça peut être je sais pas moi sur
des stocks de de salades en provenance
du maroc où au milieu de grains de café
en provenance de colombie
dès lors que le transit par container
continue à fonctionner parce qu'il faut
bien qu'on se nourrissent déjà pour les
trafiquants ça ça bon ça permet de
continuer à faire tourner le produit
déjà ensuite il ya effectivement
d'autres modes d'acheminement du produit
stupéfiant notamment les mules qui les
musiques qu'on appelle les mules c'est à
dire des individus qui titin matin là la
guyane l'aéroport de cayenne pour
ramener en france 200 a320 bull est
d'aider des boulettes de cocaïne en
général par ingestion et c'est là bon à
partir du moment où il ya moins d'avions
qui circulent il ya bien forcément plus
de contrôles aussi parce qu'il ya moins
de passage et ça devient un petit peu
plus compliqué et puis il reste encore
un mode en ces sera lé qui est le go
fast ou le gauche lo c'est à dire en
gros les voitures qui quittent l'espagne
le rapatrier sur la france soit de
l'herbe soit du cannabis et là il se
trouve que ça veut dire qu'ils ont
besoin de toute façon de continuer à
faire transiter le produit dont il ya
encore des go fast qui sont qui sont
démasqués on va dire mais forcément
c'est plus compliqué parce que l'intérêt
du trafic ans écueil et c'est de se
fondre dans la masse de la circulation à
partir du moment où cette masse elle est
moins importante vous êtes plus visible
et vous êtes plus faciles à repérer donc
le le coc vis de la crise sanitaire a eu
un impact à ce niveau là et puis après
il ya un second impact c'est vrai que
bon ben on actuellement les marchés
on va dire les marchés entre guillemets
les points de deal ont du mal à
fonctionner un à l'heure du couvre-feu
parce que là pour le coup celui qui
continue à venir s'approvisionner
après après 18 heures il est extrêmement
visible donc donc ça complique un peu
les choses mais bien je voudrais
pondérés tout ce que je viens de dire
par une chose c'est que tout cela ne
marcherait pas si en face il y avait pas
une armée de consommateurs il faut le
rappeler quand même un jeu dans les
trafiquants ils sont pas là dans leur
coin faire leur truc c'est qu'en france
vous avez la france est considérée
aujourd'hui notamment en colombie par
les trafiquants comme un eldorado
c'est à dire un endroit où il ya des
parts de marché à gagner et il ya des
consommateurs et là je ne pense pas que
le coc vide et restreint le nombre de
consommateurs au contraire parce que
vous savez que la france est un pays où
on consomme beaucoup de psychotropes 1
c'est connu et à côté de ça vous avez
d'autres gens qui vont consommer
beaucoup de produits ne serait ce que
parce que voilà contre contre la
dépression contre leur dépression il
estime que c'est le meilleur la
meilleure chose à faire donc je ne pense
pas que le marché que la consommation
est ralentie pendant cette période
au contraire merci beaucoup frédéric
ploquin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre est mon livre passionnant les
narcos français brise l'omerta c'est aux
éditions albin michel merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis sachez que vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast sur
le site rtl france point tva bientôt
[Musique]